good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and Nancy P we're going to be
looking at today is scp-173 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
item scp-173 is to be kept in a locked
container at all times when personnel
must enter scp-173 s container no fewer
than three may enter at any time and the
doors to be relocked behind them at all
times two persons must maintain direct
eye contact with scp-173 until all
personnel have vacated and relocked the
container description moved to site 19
and 1993 origin as as of yet unknown it
is constructed from concrete and rebar
with traces of Krylon brand spray-paint
scp-173 is animate and extremely hostile
the object cannot move while within a
direct line of sight line of sight must
not be broken at any time with scp-173
personnel assigned to enter container
are instructed to alert one another
before blinking object is reported to
attack by snapping the neck at the base
of the skull or by strangulation in the
event of an attack personnel are to
observe class for hazardous object
containment procedures personnel report
sounds of scraping stone originating
from within the container when no one is
present inside this is considered normal
and any change in this behavior should
be reported to the acting HM CL
supervisor on duty
the reddish-brown substance on the floor
is a combination of feces and blood
origin of these materials is unknown the
enclosure must be cleaned on a bi-weekly
basis
addendum 173 you during a site wide
incursion on May 16th 2018 scp-173
breached containment a pair of d-class
personnel were able to lure the object
into scp-914 s containment chamber it is
believed that the personnel were
attempting to destroy scp-173 by
utilizing scp-914 s ruff setting during
this attempt one of the individuals
became trapped within scp-914 input
chamber alongside scp-173 the other
d-class changed the object setting to
one-to-one and activated the machine
before escaping scp-173 survived the
process and was apparently unharmed
however its physical appearances now
altered the trap d-class was not
recovered and this is audio log 173 u1
during the breach it appears that a pair
of d-class lord 173 into 914 s
containment cell I've had looked over
the surveillance logs and it appears the
original plan was to simply enclose it
in the chamber and lock the door there
was a complication when the younger of
the two became trapped in the input
booth alongside 173 seemingly in a panic
the older d-class attempted to try and
free the younger d-class but being
inexperienced in operating 914 he
started pressing or twisting any button
or dialing could the old the d-class
accidentally activated 914 on the
one-to-one setting
judging by the security footage this
wasn't his intention as the older
d-class was observed to be extremely
distressed and immediately fled the
containment chamber the problem is that
there is a lot about this version of
scp-173 we don't understand it appears
to behave in a similar manner as before
which the other d-class learned the hard
way but the full extent of the physical
changes are still under review testing
indicates it does not have any new
abilities beyond at the facial patterns
altering overtime which seems to be
purely cosmetic as far as we've observed
they don't seem to reflect scp-173 mood
or intent the physical appearance has
drastically changed as well we'll keep
testing until we're sure that these
cosmetic changes aren't indicative of
anything else turns out that the rebar
actually is underneath there you know
what I always could never figure it out
how they knew rebar was under there now
I guess we'll never know anyway thank
you for listening if indeed you still
are and you are all dismissed goodbye
you know what
I kind of miss the little peanut
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert GM's
Sabah Chris all pablo ice 917 Karim el
ash mooing Justin day Thomas Morin Curie
kuma white crew and jayvo Jack witch
doctor crystal Roos my archive curator
Nick Joseph Lewis ooh eggy agent vamp
King modding Drakkar The Wanderer on
Joshua Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volga thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]
you